um now are george clooney and elton john
right to use their fame to urge people
to boycott the dorchester hotel
hotel chain which is owned by the sultan
of brunei
clooney started the boycott when the
country introduced a new law
which means anyone found guilty of
homosexuality or adultery
can be whipped or stoned to death now i
accept that individual governments
entitled to make their own laws
especially when they have the support of
the people but i also believe
it's time that despotic illiberal
governments
discovered that their actions have
consequences i sincerely hope that when
the likes of george clooney and elton
john
urge people not to go to brunei's luxury
hotels
around the world would be customers take
notice
that way the sultan might understand
that there are a lot of people
who disagree with these barbaric
policies i'm all
for these celebrities calling out wrongs
where they see them
good one george
[Music]
okay of course my feeling is that it's
bob it's a barbaric
law that's about to be brought in and
yes of course we should
try and change that do i think george
clooney calling on a whole load of rich
dudes not to use
nine hotels around the world i think
it'll have no effect whatsoever do i
think
there's a bit of virtue signaling on the
part of the man who will
no doubt one day run for president yes
hell yes i do
because clooney is a smart guy he knows
better than most people
that hollywood does a truckload of
business with saudi whose human rights
abuses
are every bit as bad if not worse than
brunei
he also knows that he also has said that
he doesn't think this would work but he
said he hopes that
that it would put pressure on the people
doing business
with the the banks and the institutions
doing business
with the sultan of brunei no it won't
because the sultan's worth 20 billion
dollars
the banks aren't going to lose business
over this and you know you might
remember you remember greg there was
there was a ban
at the beverly hills hotel four or five
years ago when the sultan brought first
brought in
harsher aspects of sharia law and um it
came and went
and i and i think this will tell i think
and there's there's a guy who's
how do you pronounce his name bill maher
bill maher america the the
the cnn host he he called clooney a
hypocrite he said this is
and if i can say the words he said it's
chicken tokenism because he knows it's
not going anywhere but it makes clooney
sound good well it it might makes
be intended to make clooney sound good i
happen to think that it's something he
believes
and what he's done is used his fame to
say look this isn't acceptable
and that seems to me to be perfectly
valid in a world where people don't
by and large listen to politicians they
do listen to the likes of clooney
but he's talking to he's talking to a
very small cabal
of rich people you have to be quite rich
to stay in there you're assuming that
it's only about
saying you're assuming it's about trying
to persuade people not to stay at the
hotels it's not about that at all it's
about getting the publicity
so that we sit and discuss it here we
wouldn't be discussing the sultan
and how do you think why is a monarchy
how are we going to change i think
you're right harold that
the boycott of hotels i mean i can't
speak for you greg but i personally
can't afford to stay in dorchester but
it's it has you know i think first of
all it is important to take a stand and
you if everybody only took a stand based
on how much effect it would have then a
lot of the change we've seen
wouldn't have happened here is a group
of people in eling people who probably
also can't afford to stay at the
dorchester
using this to rally momentum around
their protest have a look at this
in 2019 countries
on this planet that are stoning to death
their citizens
for being homosexual is barbaric and
we're here to tell the sultan that
we know where he lives here in healing
we don't want him that we're here
we're queer and we're picked off you
know full disclosure
i am a trustee of a charity called the
death penalty project which
strategically litigates to abolish the
death penalty in countries around the
world
i am totally answering the death penalty
i think george clooney could use some of
his celebrity to challenge
the more barbaric aspects of
state-sponsored execution in america
personally which
has a pretty terrible human rights
record when it comes to that i think it
is really important to take a stand and
you know it's not just about the hotels
uh the royal family has excellent
relationships with the sultan and
brunei's family
the commonwealth which last week we were
discussing how amazing and wonderful a
club it is enforcing the great standards
around the world
brunei is a member of the commonwealth
where where is this club of shared
values when it comes to standing against
something that moves in the completely
wrong direction
why not take saudis and we should and
i've said that i agree with that
there's 72 countries i think the source
stone will have come up with the 72
countries around the world
that are still against same-sex
relationships and punished for it
that to me is just insane it's
incredible it's it's it's well out of
order
it's gone well over beyond the money a
lot of those laws were brought in by the
british empire
and our imperial legacies that we had a
directive
i'm just reminding whoever brought them
in all right it was brought in ages ago
okay
we're getting rid of them we've torn
those barriers down and i do agree with
you greg
we should be tearing them down against
countries that don't apply of those
rules in their in their lifestyles we
shouldn't be doing business with them i
i'm strong with that as well i think the
impact will be because in
in reality as we all know he's a
fabulously ridiculously rich individual
he it won't bother him if nobody stays
in one of his hotels it actually won't
affect his bottom line so what do you
think
i hope it would bring about oh i think
it brings about this debate it brings
about
all sorts of good publicity i i don't
think that's true
right i suspect that they that that's
been looking at this and been looking at
the publicity this is getting all around
the world and saying
we don't like this much but if you're so
crazed you're prepared to
to kill someone simply because they
happen to be gay or they're asking do
you
mean you're not even on this earth are
you not rational why would you you know
i mean we have to be careful sometimes
because you've only got to go back 40 50
years and
and we didn't stone people today but it
was illegal yeah but you weren't put to
death
no were you the idea that the sultan is
going to go through the receipts at the
polo lounge
and say oh i only sold four soups a day
no he doesn't care
he's not going i doubt whether that's
true i think people who have businesses
they will if if their business uh
results drop they care
regardless of how much money they got so
the interesting thing about them
they care but i don't think that will
happen
i think by and large if the daughter
will carry on as it is i think
can i just can i just ask quickly let me
just ask this
you know there's been not to talk about
clooney at some point going for the
presidency do you not think this is
actually just
a bid to make him sound like a caring
politician no i think this is clearly
saying something that he
he feels strongly about and he's always
said things he feels strongly about
i've got quite a lot of respect for him
for the things over the years he's not
upsetting the saudis i think
he should have expanded that comment to
include everybody that has a beef
with but you only have to look at what
happened with
khashoggi the journalist was murdered by
saudi which was horrific
saudi was hugely embarrassed by the
reputational damage that caused even if
it hasn't actually i don't think it's
changed anything particularly so far
every country cares about standing in
the world
and brunei enjoys excellent
relationships with the uk
it wants to be part of the club of
western nations as well here's what
penny mordant has said the international
development secretary
no one should face the death penalty
because of who they love brunei's
decision is barbaric and the uk stands
with the lg lgbt plus community and
those who defend their rights
lgbt plus rights are human rights now
again and i totally link this to the
conversation about saudi i'm always
curious to see
what will follow from these nice strong
statements from british politicians
condemning things but do we put
our money where our mouth is and this is
a moment i mean we're not talking about
brexit in this debate
but we are redefining our stance on the
global stage this is about
who we will be in the future what do we
stand for now talk about putting where
your money where your mouth is you don't
have enough cash to stay at the
dorchester some people do so let's see
what the dorchester collection says and
its code emphasizes equality respect
and integrity in all areas of our
operation and strongly values people and
cultural diversity
among our guests and employees inclusion
and diversity remain core beliefs
as we do not tolerate any form of
discrimination
time will tell on this greg won't you i
suppose well i i suspect if you're the
guy who's running
the dorchester you must be sitting there
going i could have done without this
couldn't i
so i mean i don't think we should think
that it has no impact it will have an
impact on the business
does it matter the sound of berlin yeah
i think you're right
that that sort of publicity that sort of
demonstration of what
is so illiberal which is such an
appalling law
i i think will will affect them over
time i mean
you you can't just do this and hope that
everything doesn't
what did you do but but this is not the
first time there have been
uh protestations about what is happening
brunei
and nothing has happened it's a monarchy
there's nothing we can do to change of
course it's barbaric of course no
civilized
human being would agree with what he's
doing but i don't see a load of rich
people in hollywood actually changing
that but isn't that the reason why you
have to point it out
that because he's rich because he
doesn't have to change it has to be
pointed out
how the public has to know in la in
large numbers